يشهد قطاع السياحه في السعوديه نموا
متسارعا ما يجعلها بيئه محفزه لتطوير
ممارسه الانشطه السياحيه تحقيقا لاهداف
رؤيه المملكه 2030 وذلك من خلال اعتماد
لائحه تسمح للسعوديين بتاجير وحداتهم
السكنيه للسياح المزيد مع مراسلنا علي
[موسيقى]
لائحه مرافق ضيافه السياحي الخاص والتي
تسمح للمواطنين بتاجير وحداتهم السكنيه
ضمن عقار مخصص للاستخدام السكني او
الزراعي اجراء يسهم في دعم تجربه النزول
الريفيه في واحه الاحساء والتعرف على
العادات الاجتماعيه والثقافيه للمنطقه قد
تكون الاحصاء اكثر المستفيدين من هذا
القرار بحكمون فيها جزء كبير من السياحه
الزراعيه ومن ضمن السياحه الزراعيه وجود
نزول الريفيه اللي عددها فوق تقريبا فوق
الاكثر من 1000 نزل ريفيه وجودها وتصريحها
وتكون تحت مظله اللي هو وزاره السياحه راح
يعطيها دفعه الى الامام خصوصا بانها تكون
تحت اشراطات معينه من قبل الوزاره راح
تعطي اللي هو خدمات افضل وراح تعطي اللي
هو اللي هو يعني استفاده كبيره للسواع
تضيف للمراهق السياحيه الخاصه خلق
التنافسيه في جوده الخدمات وفق الضوابط
والاشتراطات وتنوع التجارب السياحيه كما
تساعد على حفظ الطابع الشعبي
للدخل المالي لمالكها مبادره ممتازه جدا
تتيح المجال للزائر له سهوله البحث على
السكن كذلك تحل ازمه العجز في البحث عن
السكن وتعطي مجال للتنوع لا سيما ان
السائح او الزائر يبحث عن الهويه المحليه
اذا كان عندها تنوع سواء في نزل ريفيه او
في الى احد المنازل بالاضافه الى الفنادق
المتاحه فهذا يعطي مجال جميل جدا للسائح
خصوصا ان الزائر يبحث عن الهويه المحليه
تصريح معالي وزير السياحه حول استثمار
المزارع في الاحساء والقصيم تصريح مهم جدا
للغايه لان يوفر نزل السياح
اصحاب المزارع رايحين يستثمروا في هذه
الحاله سيعود بالراعه ايضا على الاقتصاد
الوطني ويصنع خيارات متعدده للسياح في
المنطقه فرص وظيفيه واستثماريه تحققها
المرافق السياحيه الخاصه كما تقوم على
تطوير صناعه الضيافه السياحيه وايجاد
تجارب خلاقه للسياحه في السعوديه من
الاحساء علي اللغبي العربيه